Good morning.
Today we're going to talk about
augmenting data structures.
And this is a --
Normally, rather than designing
data structures from scratch,
you tend to take existing data
structures and build your
functionality into them.
And that is a process we call
data-structure augmentation.
And this also today marks sort
of the start of the design phase
of the class.
We spent a lot of time doing
analysis up to this point.
And now we're still going to
learn some new analytical
techniques.
But we're going to start
turning our focus more toward
how is it that you design
efficient data structures,
efficient algorithms for
various problems?
So this is a good example of
the design phase.
It is a really good idea,
at this point,
if you have not done so,
to review the textbook Appendix
B.
You should take that as
additional reading to make sure
that you are familiar,
because over the next few weeks
we're going to hit almost every
topic in Appendix B.
It is going to be brought to
bear on the subjects that we're
talking about.
If you're going to go scramble
to learn that while you're also
trying to learn the material,
it will be more onerous than if
you just simply review the
material now.
We're going to start with an
illustration of the problem of
dynamic order statistics.
We are familiar with finding
things like the median or the
kth order statistic or whatever.
Now we want to do the same
thing but we want to do it with
a dynamic set.
Rather than being given all the
data upfront,
we're going to have a set.
And then at some point somebody
is going to be doing typically
insert and delete.
And at some point somebody is
going to say OK,
select for me the ith largest
guy or the ith smallest guy --
-- in the dynamic set.
Or, something like OS-Rank of
x.
The rank of x in the sorted
order of the set.
So either I want to just say,
for example,
if I gave n over 2,
if I had n elements in the set
and I said n over 2,
I am asking for the median.
I could be asking for the mean.
I could be asking for quartile.
Here I take an element and say,
OK, so where does that element
fall among all of the other
elements in the set?
And, in addition,
these are dynamic sets so I
want to be able to do insert and
delete, I want to be able to add
and remove elements.
The solution we are going to
look at for this one,
the basic idea is to keep the
sizes of subtrees in the nodes
of a red-black tree.
Let me draw a picture as an
example.
In this tree --
I didn't draw the NILs for
this.
I am going to keep two values.
I am going to keep the key.
And so for the keys,
what I will do is just use
letters of the alphabet.
And this is a red-black tree.
Just for practice,
how can I label this tree so
it's a red-black tree?
I haven't shown the NILs.
Remember the NILs are all
black.
How can I label this,
red and black?
Make sure it is a red-black
tree.
Not every tree can be labeled
as a red-black tree,
right?
This is good practice because
this sort of thing shows up on
quizzes.
Make F red, good,
and everything else black,
that is certainly a solution.
Because then that basically
brings the level of this guy up
to here.
Actually, I had a more
complicated one because it
seemed like more fun.
What I did was I made this guy
black and then these two guys
red and black and red,
black and red,
black and black.
But your solution is perfectly
good as well.
So we don't have any two reds
in a row on any path.
And all the black height from
any particular point going down
we get the same number of blacks
whichever way we go.
Good.
The idea here now is that,
we're going to keep the subtree
sizes, these are the keys that
are stored in our dynamic set,
we're going to keep the subtree
sizes in the red-black tree.
For example,
this guy has size one.
These guys have size one
because they're leaves.
And then we can just work up.
So this has size three,
this guy has size five,
this guy has size three,
and this guy has five plus
three plus one is nine.
In general, we will have size
of x is equal to size of left of
x plus the size of the right
child of x plus one.
That is how I compute it
recursively.
A very simple formula for what
the size is.
It turns out that for the code
that we're going to want to
write to implement these
operations, it is going to be
convenient to be talking about
the size of NIL.
So what is the size of NIL?
Zero.
Size of NIL,
there are no elements there.
However, in most program
languages, if I take size of
NIL, what will happen?
You get an error.
That is kind of inconvenient.
What I have to do in my code is
that everywhere that I might
want to take size of NIL,
or take the size of anything,
I have to say,
well, if it's NIL then return
zero, otherwise return the size
field, etc.
There is an implementation
trick that we're going to use to
simplify that.
It's called using a sentinel.
A sentinel is nothing more than
a dummy record.
Instead of using a NIL,
we will actually use a NIL
sentinel.
We will use a dummy record for
NIL such that size of NIL is
equal to zero.
Instead of any place I would
have used NIL in the tree,
instead I will have a special
record that I will call NIL.
But it will be a whole record.
And that way I can set its size
field to be zero,
and then I don't have to check
that as a special case.
That is a very common type of
programming trick to use,
is to use sentinels to simplify
code so you don't have all these
boundary cases or you don't have
to write an extra function when
all I want to do is just index
the size of something.
Everybody with me on that?
So let's write the code for
OS-Select given this
representation.
And this is going to basically
give us the ith smallest in the
subtree rooted at x.
It's actually going to be a
little bit more general.
If I want to implement the
OS-Select i of up there,
I basically give it the root
n_i.
But we're going to build this
recursively so it's going to be
helpful to have the node in
which we're trying to find the
subtree.
Here is the code.
This is the code.
And let's just see how it works
and then we will argue why it
works.
As an example,
let's do OS-Select of the root
and 5.
We're going to find the fifth
largest in the set.
We have OS-Select of the root
and 5.
This is inconvenient.
We start out at the top,
well, let's just switch the
boards.
Here we go.
We start at the top,
and i is the root.
Excuse me, i is 5,
sorry, and the root.
i=5.
We want to five the fifth
largest.
We first compute this value k.
00:13:35 --> 1.
k is the size of left of x plus
1. --> 00:13:39
What is that value?
What is k anyway?
What is it?
Well, in this case it is 6.
Good.
But what is the meaning of k?
The order.
The rank.
Good, the rank of the current
node.
This is the rank of the current
k is always the size of the
left subtree plus 1.
That is just the rank of the
current node.
We look here and we say,
well, the rank is k.
Now, if it is equal then we
found the element we want.
But, otherwise,
if i is less,
we know it's going to be in the
left subtree.
All we're doing then is
recursing in the left subtree.
And here we will recurse.
We will want the fifth largest
one.
And now this time k is going to
be equal to what?
Two.
Now here we say,
OK, this is bigger,
so therefore the element we
want is going to be in the right
subtree.
But we don't want the ith
largest guy in the right
subtree, because we already know
there are going to be two guys
over here.
We want the third largest guy
in this subtree.
We have i equals 3 as we
recurse into this subtree.
And now we compute k for here.
This plus 1 is 2.
And that says we recursed right
here.
And then we have i=1,
k=1, and we return in this code
a pointer to this node.
So this returns a pointer to
the node containing H whose key
is H.
Just to make a comment here,
we discovered k is equal to the
rank of x.
Any questions about what is
going on in this code?
OK.
It's basically just finding its
way down.
The subtree sizes help it make
the decision as to which way it
should go to find which is the
ith largest.
We can do a quick analysis.
On our red-black tree,
how long does OS-Select take to
run?
Yeah?
Yeah, order log n if there are
n elements in the tree.
Because the red-black tree is a
balance tree.
Its height is order log n.
In fact, this code will work on
any tree that has order log n
the height of the tree.
And so if you have a guaranteed
height, the way that red-black
trees do, you're in good shape.
OS-Rank, we won't do but it is
in the book, also gets order log
n.
Here is a question I want to
pose.
Why not just keep the ranks
themselves?
Yeah?
It's the node itself.
Otherwise, you cannot take left
of it.
I mean, if we were doing this
in a decent language,
strongly typed language there
would be no confusion.
But we're writing in this
pseudocode that is good because
it's compact,
which lets you focus on the
algorithm.
But, of course,
it doesn't have a lot of the
things you would really want if
you were programming things of
scale like type safety and so
forth.
Yeah?
It is basically hard to
maintain when you modify it.
For example,
if we actually kept the ranks
in the nodes,
certainly it would be easy to
find the element of a given
rank.
But all I have to do is insert
the smallest element,
an element that is smaller than
all of the other elements.
And what happens?
All the ranks have to be
changed.
Order n changes have to be made
if that's what I was
maintaining, whereas with
subtree sizes that's a lot
easier.
Because it's hard to maintain
--
-- when the red-black tree is
modified.
And that is the other sort of
tricky thing when you're
augmenting a data structure.
You want to put in the things
that your operations go fast,
but you cannot forget that
there are already underlying
operations on the data structure
that have to be maintained in
some way.
Can we close this door,
please?
Thank you.
We have to look at what are the
modifying operations and how do
we maintain them.
The modifying operations for
red-black trees are insert and
delete.
If I were augmenting a binary
heap, what operations would I
have to worry about?
If I were augmenting a heap,
what are the modifying
operations?
Binary min heap,
for example,
classic priority queue?
Who remembers heaps?
What are the operations on a
heap?
There's a good final question.
Take-home exam,
don't worry about it.
Final, worry about it.
What are the operations on a
heap?
Just look it up on Books24 or
whatever it is,
right?
AnswerMan?
What does AnswerMan say?
OK.
And?
If it's a min heap.
It's min, extract min,
typical operations and insert.
And of those which are
modifying?
Insert and extract min,
OK?
So, min is not.
You don't have to worry about
min because all that is is a
query.
You want to distinguish
operations on a dynamic data
structure those that modify and
those that don't,
because the ones that don't
modify the data structure are
all perfectly fine as long as
you haven't destroyed
information.
The queries,
those are easy.
But the operations that modify
the data structure,
those we're very concerned
about in making sure we can
maintain.
Our strategy for dealing with
insert and delete in this case
is to update the subtree sizes
--
-- when inserting or deleting.
For example,
let's look at what happens when
I insert k.
Element key k.
I am going to want to insert it
in here, right?
What is going to happen to this
subtree size if I am inserting k
in here?
00:23:20 --> 10.
This is going to increase to
10. --> 00:23:25
And then I go left.
This one is going to increase
to 6.
Here it is going to increase to
00:23:41 --> 4.
4. --> 00:23:42
Here 2.
And then I will put my k down
there with a 1.
So I just updated on the way
down.
Pretty easy.
Yeah?
But now it's not a red-black
tree anymore.
You have to rebalance,
so you must also handle
rebalancing.
Because, remember,
and this is something that
people tend to forget so it's
always, I think,
helpful when I see patterns
going on to tell everybody what
the pattern is so that you can
be sure of it in your work that
you're not falling into that
pattern.
What people tend to forget when
they're doing red-black trees is
they tend to remember the tree
insert part of it,
but red-black insert,
that RB insert procedure
actually has two parts to it.
First you call tree insert and
then you have to rebalance.
And so you've got to make sure
you do the whole of the
red-black insert.
Not just the tree insert part.
We just did the tree insert
part.
That was easy.
We also have to handle
rebalancing.
So there are two types of
things we have to worry about.
One is red-black color changes.
Well, unfortunately those have
no effect on subtree sizes.
If I change the colors of
things, no effect,
no problem.
But also the interesting one is
rotations.
Rotations, it turns out,
are fairly easy to fix up.
Because when I do a rotation,
I can update the nodes based on
the children.
I will show you that.
You basically look at children
and fix up, in this case,
in order one time per rotation.
For example,
imagine that I had a piece of
my tree that looked like this.
And let's say it was 7,
3, 4, the subtree sizes.
I'm not going to put the values
in here.
And I did a right rotation on
that edge to put them the other
way.
And so these guys get hooked up
this way.
Always the three children stay
as three children.
We just swing this guy over to
there and make this guy be the
parent of the other one.
And so now the point is that I
can just simply update this guy
to be, well, he's got 8,
3 plus 4 plus 1 using our
formula for what the size is.
And now, for this one,
it's going to be 8 plus 7 plus
1 is 16, or, if I think about
it, it's going to be whatever
that was before because I
haven't changed this subtree
size with a rotation.
Everything beneath this edge is
still beneath this edge.
And so I fixed it up in order
one time.
There are certain other types
of operations sometimes that
occur where this isn't the
value.
If I wasn't doing subtree sizes
but was doing some other
property of the subtree,
it could be that this was no
longer 16 in which case the
effect might propagate up
towards the root.
There is a nice little lemma in
the book that shows the
conditions under which you can
make sure that the re-balancing
doesn't cost you too much.
So that was pretty good.
Now, insert and delete,
that is all we have to do for
rotations, are therefore still
order log n time,
because a red-black tree only
has to do order one rotations.
Do they normally take constant
time?
Well, they still take constant
time.
They just take a little bit
bigger constant.
And so now we've been able to
build this great data structure
that supports dynamic order
statistic queries and it works
in order log n time for insert,
delete and the various queries.
OS-Select.
I can also just search for an
element.
I have taken the basic data
structure and have added some
new operations on it.
Any questions about what we did
here?
Do people understand this
reasonably well?
OK.
Then let's generalize,
always a dangerous thing.
Augmenting data structures.
What I would like to do is give
you a little methodology for how
you go about doing this safely
so you don't forget things.
The most common thing,
by the way, if there is an
augmentation problem on the
take-home or if there is one on
the final, I guarantee that
probably a quarter of the class
will forget the rotations if
they augmented red-black tree.
I guarantee it.
Anyway, here is a little
methodology to check yourself.
As I mentioned,
the reason why this is so
important is because this is,
in practice,
the thing that you do most of
the time.
You don't just use a data
structure as given.
You take a data structure.
You say I have my own
operations I want to layer onto
this.
We're going to give a
methodology.
And what I will do,
as I go along,
is will use the example of
order statistics trees to
illustrate the methodology.
It is four steps.
The first is choose an
underlying data structure.
Which in the case of order
statistics tree was what?
Red-black tree.
And the second thing we do is
we figure out what additional
information we wish to maintain
in that data structure.
Which in this case is the
subtree sizes.
Subtree sizes is what we keep
for this one.
And when we did this we could
make mistakes,
right?
We could have said,
oh, let's keep the rank.
And we start playing with it
and discover we can do that.
It just goes really slowly.
It takes some creativity to
figure out what is the
information that you're going to
be able to keep,
but also to maintain the other
properties that you want.
The third step is verify that
the information can be
maintained --
-- for the modifying operations
on the data structure.
And so in this case,
for OS trees,
the modifying operations were
insert and delete.
And, of course,
we had to make sure we dealt
with rotations.
And because rotations are part
of that we could break it down
into the tree insert,
the tree delete and rotations.
And once we've did that
everything was fine.
We didn't, for this particular
problem, have to worry about
color changes.
But that's another thing that
under some things you might have
to worry about.
For some reason the color made
a difference.
Usually that doesn't make a
difference.
And then the fourth step is to
develop new operations.
Presumably that use the info
that you have now stored.
And this was OS-Select and
OS-Rank, which we didn't give
but which is there.
And also it's a nice little
puzzle to figure out yourself,
how you would build OS-Rank.
Not a hard piece of code.
This methodology is not
actually the way you do this.
This is one of these things
that's more like a checklist,
because you see whether or not
you've got --
When you're actually doing this
maybe you developed the new
operations first.
You've got to keep in mind the
new operations while you're
verifying that the information
you're storing can be here.
Maybe you will then go back and
change this and sort of sort
through it.
This is more a checklist that
when you're done this is how you
write it up.
This is how you document that
what you've done is,
in fact, a good thing.
You have a checklist.
Here is my underlying data
structure.
Here is the addition
information I need.
See, I can still support the
modifying operations that the
data structure used to have and
now here are my new operations
and see what those are.
It's really a checklist.
Not a prescription for the
order in which you do things.
You must do all these steps,
not necessarily in this order.
This is a guide for your
documentation.
When we ask for you to augment
a data structure,
generally we're asking you to
tell us what the four steps are.
It will help you organize your
things.
It will also help make sure you
don't forget some step along the
way.
I've seen people who have added
the information and developed
new operations but completely
forgot to verify that the
information could be maintained.
So you want to make sure that
you've done all those.
Usually you have to play --
-- with interactions --
-- between steps.
It's not just a do this,
do this, do this.
We're going to do now a more
complicated data structure.
It's not that much more
complicated, but its correctness
is actually kind of challenging.
And it is actually a very
practical and useful data
structure.
I am amazed at how many people
aren't aware that there are data
structures of this nature that
are useful for them when I see
people writing really slow code.
And so the example we're going
to do is interval trees.
And the idea of this is that we
want to maintain a set of
intervals.
For example,
time intervals.
I have a whole database of time
intervals that I'm trying to
maintain.
Let's just do an example here.
This is going from 7 to 10,
5 to 11 and 4 to 8,
from 15 to 18,
17 to 19 and 21 to 23.
This is a set of intervals.
And if we have an interval i,
let's say this is interval i,
which is 7,10.
We're going to call this
endpoint the low endpoint of i
and this we're going to call the
high endpoint of i.
The reason I use low and high
rather than left or right is
because we're going to have a
tree, and we're going to want
the left subtree and the right
subtree.
So if I start saying left and
right for intervals and left and
right for tree we're going to
get really confused.
This is also a tip.
Let me say when you're coding,
you really have to think hard
sometimes about the words that
you're using for things,
especially things like left and
right because they get so
overused throughout programming.
It's a good idea to come up
with a whole wealth of synonyms
for different situations so that
it is clear in any piece of code
when you're talking,
for example,
about the intervals versus the
tree, because we're going to
have both going on here.
And what we're going to do is
we want to support insertion and
deletion of intervals here.
And we're going to have a
query, which is going to be the
new operation we're going to
develop, which is going to be to
find an interval,
any interval in the set that
overlaps a given query interval.
So I give you a query interval
like say 6, 14 and you can
return this guy or this guy,
this guy, couldn't return any
of these because these are all
less than 14.
So I can return any one of
those.
I only have to return one.
I just have to find one guy
that overlaps.
Any question about what we're
going to be setting up here?
OK.
Our methodology is we're going
to pick, first of all,
step one.
And here is our methodology.
Step one is we're going chose
underlying data structure.
Does anybody have a suggestion
as to what data structure we
ought to use here to support
interval trees?
What data structure should we
try to start here to support
interval trees?
Anybody have any idea?
A red-black tree.
A binary search tree.
Red-black tree.
We're going to use a red-black
tree.
Oh, I've got to say what it is
keyed on.
What is going to be the key for
my red-black tree?
For each interval,
what should I use for a key?
This is where there are a bunch
of options, right?
Throw out some ideas.
It's always better to branch
than it is to prune.
You can always prune later,
but if you don't branch you
will never get the chance to
prune.
So generation of ideas.
You'll need that when you're
doing the design phase and doing
the take-home exam.
Yeah?
We're calling that the low
endpoint.
OK, you could do low endpoint.
What other ideas are there?
High end point.
Now you can look at low
endpoint, high endpoint.
Well, between low and high
which is better?
That one is not going to
matter, right?
So doing high versus low,
we don't have to consider that,
but there is another natural
point you want to think about
using like the median,
the middle point.
At least that is symmetric.
What do you think?
What else might I use?
The length?
I think the length doesn't feel
to me productive.
This is just purely a matter of
intuition.
It doesn't feel productive,
because if I know the length I
don't know where it is so it's
going to be hard to maintain
information about where it is
for queries.
It turns out we're going to use
the low left endpoint,
but I think to me that was sort
of a surprise that you'd want to
use that and not the middle one.
Because you're favoring one
endpoint over the other.
It turns out that's the right
thing to do, surprisingly.
There is another strategy.
Actually, there's another type
of tree called a segment tree.
Actually, what you do is you
store both the left and right
endpoints separately in the
tree.
And then you maintain a data
structure where the line
segments go up through the tree
on to the other.
There are lots of things you
can do, but we're just going to
keep it keyed on the low
endpoint.
That's why this is a more
clever data structure in some
ways.
Now, this is harder.
That is why this is a clever
data structure.
What are we going to store in
the --
I think any of those ideas are
good ideas to throw out and look
at.
You don't know which one is
going to work until you play
with it.
This one, though,
is, I think,
much harder to guess.
You're going to store in a node
the largest value,
I will call it m,
in the subtree rooted at that
node.
We'll draw it like this,
a node like this.
We will put the interval here
and we will put the m value
here.
Let's draw a picture.
Once again, I am not drawing
the NILs.
I hope that that is a search
tree that is keyed on the low
left endpoint.
4, 5, 7, 15,
17, 21.
It is keyed on the low left
endpoint.
If this a red-black tree,
let's just do another practice.
How can I color this so that it
is a legal red-black tree?
Not too relevant to what we're
doing right now
But a little drill doesn't hurt
sometimes.
Remember, the NILs are not
there and they are all black.
And the root is black.
I will give that one to you.
Good.
This will work.
You sort of go through a little
puzzle.
A logic puzzle.
Because this is really short so
it better not have any reds in
it.
This has got to be black.
Now, if I'm going to balance
the height, I have got to have a
layer of black here.
It couldn't be that one.
It's got to be these two.
Good.
Now let's compute the m value
for each of these.
It's the largest value in the
subtree rooted at that node.
What's the largest value in the
00:48:36 --> 10.
subtree rooted at this node?
10. --> 00:48:43
00:48:43 --> 18.
And in this one?
18. --> 00:48:47
00:48:47 --> 8.
In this one?
8. --> 00:48:50
00:48:50 --> 18.
18. --> 00:49:00
That one is 23 and that is 23.
In general, m is going to be
the maximum of three possible
values.
Either the high point of the
interval at x or m of the left
of x or m of the right of x.
Does everybody see that?
It is going to be m of x for
any node.
I just have to look,
what is the maximum here,
what is the maximum here and
what is the high point of the
interval.
Whichever one of those is
largest, that's the largest for
that subtree.
The modifying operations.
Let's first do insert.
How can I do insert?
There are two parts.
The first part is to do the
tree insert, just a normal
insert into a binary search
tree.
What do I do?
Insert a new interval?
Insert a new interval here?
How can I fix up the m's?
That's right.
You just go down the tree and
look at my current interval.
And if it's got a bigger max,
this is something that is going
into that subtree.
If its high endpoint is bigger
than the current max,
update the current max.
I just do that as I'm going
through the insertion,
wherever it happens to land up
in every subtree that it hits,
every node that it hits on the
way down.
I just update it with the
maximum wherever it happens to
fall.
Good.
You just fix them on the way
down.
But we also have to do the
other section.
Also need to handle rotations.
So let's just see how we might
do rotations as an example.
Let's say this is 11, 15, 30.
Let's say I'm doing a right
rotation.
This is coming off from
somewhere.
That is coming off.
This is still going to be the
child that has 30,
the one that 14 and the one
that has 19.
And so now we've rotated this
way, so this is the 11,
15 and this is the 6,
00:53:53 --> 20.
20. --> 00:53:55
For this one,
I just use my formula here.
I just look here and say which
is the biggest,
14, 15 or 19?
00:54:04 --> 19.
19. --> 00:54:06
And I look here.
Which is the biggest?
30, 19 or 20?
00:54:08 --> 30.
30. --> 00:54:10
Or, once again,
it turns out,
not too hard to show,
that it's always whatever was
there, because we're talking
about the biggest thing in the
subtree.
And the membership of the
subtree hasn't changed when we
do the rotation.
That just took me order one
time to fix up.
Fixing up the m's during
rotation takes O(1) time.
So the total insert time is
O(lg n).
Once I figured out that this is
the right information,
of course we don't know what
we're using this information for
yet.
But once I know that that is
the information,
showing you that it works in
certain delete continuing work
in order log n time is easy.
Now, delete is actually a
little bit trickier but I will
just say it is similar.
Because in delete you go
through and you find something,
you may have to go through the
whole business of swapping it.
If it's an internal node you've
got to swap it with its
successor or predecessor.
And so there are a bunch of
things that have to be dealt
with, but it is all stuff where
you can update the information
using this thing.
And it's all essentially local
changes when you're updating
this information because you can
do it essentially only on a path
up from the root and most of the
tree is never dealt with.
I will leave that for you folks
to work out.
It's also in the book if you
want to cheat,
but it is a good exercise.
Any questions about the first
three steps?
Fourth step is new operations.
Interval search of i is going
to find an interval that
overlaps the interval i.
So i here is an interval.
It's got two coordinates.
And this, rather than writing
recursively, we're going to
write as, it's sort of going to
be recursive,
but we're going to write it
with a while loop.
You could write it recursively.
The other one that we wrote,
we could have written as a
while loop as well and not had
the recursive call.
Here we're going to basically
just start x gets the root.
And then while --
That is the code.
Let's just see how it works.
Let's search for the interval
14, 16 --
-- in this tree.
Let's see.
x starts out at the root.
And while it is not NIL,
and it's not NIL because it's
the root, what is this doing?
Somebody tell me what that code
does.
Well, what is this doing?
This is testing something
between i and int of x.
Int of x is the interval stored
at x.
What is this testing for?
I hope I got it right.
What is this testing for? Yeah?
Above or below?
I need just simple words.
Test for overlaps.
In particular test whether they
do or don't?
Do?
Don't?
If I get to this point,
what do I know about i and int
of x?
Don't overlap.
They don't overlap because the
high of one is smaller than the
low of the other.
The high of one is smaller than
the low of the other.
They don't overlap that way.
Could they overlap the other
way?
No because we're testing also
whether the low of the one is
bigger than the high of the
other.
They're saying it's either like
this or like this.
This is testing not overlap.
That makes it simpler.
When I'm searching for 14,
16, I check here.
And I say do they overlap?
And the answer is,
now we can understand it
without having to go through all
the arithmetic calculations,
no they don't overlap.
If they did overlap,
I found what I want.
And what's going to happen?
I am going to drop out of the
while loop and just return x,
because I will return something
that overlaps.
That is my goal.
Here it says they don't
overlap.
So then I say,
well, if left of x is not NIL,
in other words,
I've got a left child and low
of i is less than or equal to m
of left of x,
then we go left.
What happens in this case if
I'm searching for 14,
16?
Is the low of i less than or
equal to m of left of x?
Low of i is 14.
And I am searching.
And is it less than 18?
Yes.
Therefore, what do I do?
I go left and make x point to
this guy.
Now I check.
Does it overlap?
No.
I take a look at the left guy.
It is 8.
I compare 8 with 14,
right?
And is it lower?
No, so I go right.
And now I discover that I have
an overlap here and it overlaps.
It returns then the 15,
18 as an overlapping one.
1:04:55.093 --> 14.
If I were searching for 12,
14. --> 1:05:00
I would go up to the top.
And I look, 12,
14, it doesn't overlap here.
I look at the 18 and it is
greater so I go left.
I then look here.
Does it overlap?
No.
So then what happens?
I look at the left.
It says I go right.
I look here.
Then I go and I look at the
left.
It says, no,
go right.
I go here, which is NIL,
and now it is NIL.
I return NIL.
And does 12,
14 overlap anything in the set?
No.
So, therefore,
it always works.
OK?
OK.
We're going to do correctness
in a minute, but let's just do
our analysis first so we don't
have to do it because the
correctness is going to be a
little bit tricky.
Time = O(lg n) because all I am
doing is going down the tree.
It takes time proportional to
the height of the tree.
That's pretty easy.
If I need to list all overlaps,
suppose I want to list all the
overlaps, how quickly can I do
that?
Can somebody suggest how I
could use this as a subroutine
to list all overlaps?
Suppose I have k overlaps,
k intervals that overlap my
query interval and I want to
find every single one of them,
how fast can I do that?
How do I do it?
If I search a second time,
I might get the same value.
Yeah, there you go.
Do what?
When you find it delete it.
Put it over to the side.
Find the next one,
delete it until there are none
left.
And then, if I don't want to
modify the data structure,
insert them all back in.
It costs me k lg n if they are
k overlaps.
That's actually called an
output sensitive algorithm.
Because the running time of it
depends upon how much it
outputs, so this is output
sensitive.
The best to date for this
problem, by the way,
of listing all is O(k+lg n)
with a different data structure.
And, actually,
that was open for a while as an
open problem.
OK. Correctness.
Why does this algorithm always
work correctly?
The key issue of the
correctness is that I am picking
one way to go,
left or right.
And that's great,
as long as it is in that
subtree.
But how do I know that when I
pick I decide I'm going to go
left that it might not be in the
right subtree and I went the
wrong way?
Or, if I went right,
that I accidentally left one
out on the left side?
We're always going just one
direction.
And that's sort of the
cleverness of the code.
The theorem is let's let L be
the set of intervals i prime in
the left of a node x.
And R be the set of i primes in
the right of x.
And now there are two parts I
am going to show.
If the search goes right then
the set of i prime in L,
such that i prime overlaps i is
the empty set.
That's the first thing I do.
If it goes right then there is
nothing in the left subtree that
overlaps.
It's always,
whenever the code goes right,
no problem, because there was
nothing in the left subtree to
be found.
Does everybody understand what
that says?
We are going to prove this,
but I want to make sure people
understand.
Because the second one is going
to be harder to understand so
you've got to make sure you
understand this one first.
Any questions about this?
OK.
If the search goes left --
-- then the set of i prime in L
such that i prime overlaps i
empty set implies that i prime
--
OK.
What is this saying?
If the search goes left,
if the left was empty,
in other words,
if you went left and you
discovered that there was
nothing in there to find,
no overlapping interval to find
then it is OK because it
wouldn't have helped me to go
right anyway because there is
nothing in the right to be
found.
So it is not guaranteeing that
there is nothing to be found in
the left, but if there happens
to be nothing to find in the
left it is OK because there was
nothing to be found in the right
either.
That is what the second one
says.
In either case,
you're OK to go the way.
So let's do this proof.
Does everybody understand what
the proof says?
Understanding the proof is
tricky.
It's logic.
Logic is tricky.
Suppose the search goes right.
We'll do the first one.
If left of x is NIL then we are
done since we proved what we
wanted to prove.
If we go right there are two
possibilities,
either we have left of x be NIL
or left of x is not NIL.
So if it is NIL we are OK
because we said if it goes right
I want to prove this,
that the things in the left
subtree that overlap is empty.
If there is nothing there,
there is clearly nothing there
that overlaps.
Otherwise, the low of i is
greater than m of the left of x.
If I look at x here,
either x was NIL in the while
statement here or this is true.
We just said it is not NIL so
let's take a look at,
excuse me.
I'm on the wrong line.
I am in this loop.
Left of x was not NIL and the
low of i was this.
Which way am I going here?
I am going right.
Therefore, this was not true.
So either left of x was not
NIL, which was the first one,
or low of i is greater than m
of left of x if I am going
right.
If I'm going right one of those
two had to be true.
The first one was easy.
Otherwise, we have this,
low of i is greater than m of
left of x.
Now this has got to be that
value.
m of left of x is the right
endpoint, is the high endpoint
of some interval in that
subtree.
This is equal to the high of j
for some j in L.
So m of left of x must be equal
to the high of some endpoint
because that's how we're picking
the m's.
For some j in the left subtree.
And no other interval in L has
a larger high endpoint --
-- than high of j.
If I draw a picture here,
I have over here i and this is
the low of i.
And I have j where we say its
high endpoint is less than the
low of i.
This is j, and I don't know how
far over it goes.
And this has high of j --
-- which is the highest one in
the left subtree.
There is nobody else who has
got a higher right endpoint.
There is nobody else in this
subtree who could possibly
overlap I, because all of them
end somewhere before this point.
This point is the highest one
in a subtree.
Therefore, i prime in L such
that i prime overlaps i is the
empty set.
And now the hard case.
Everybody stretch.
Hard case.
Does everybody follow this?
The point is that because this
is the highest guy everybody
else has to be left,
so if you didn't overlap the
highest guy you're not going to
overlap anybody.
Suppose the search goes left --
-- and that there is nothing to
overlap in the left subtree.
I went left here but I am not
going to find anything.
Now I want to prove that it
wouldn't have helped me to go
right.
That's essentially what the
theorem here says.
That if I assume this it
wouldn't have helped to go
right.
I want to show that there is
nothing in the right subtree.
So going left was OK because I
wasn't going to find anything
anyway.
Similarly, we go through a
similar analysis.
Low of i is less than or equal
to m of the left of x,
which once again is equal to
the high of j for some j in L.
We are just saying if I go left
these things must be true.
I went left.
Since j is in L it doesn't
overlap i, because the set of
things that overlap i in L is
empty set.
Since j doesn't overlap i that
implies that the high of i must
be less than the low of j.
Since j is in L and it doesn't
overlap i, what are the
possibilities?
We essentially have here,
if I draw a picture,
I have j and L and I have i
here.
The point is that it doesn't
overlap it, therefore,
it must be to the left because
its low endpoint is less than
this.
But it doesn't overlap it,
therefore its high endpoint
must be left of the low of this
one.
Now we will use the binary
search tree property.
That implies that for all i
prime in R, everything in the
right subtree,
we have a low of j is less than
or equal to low of i prime,
so we're sorted on the low
endpoints.
Everything in the right subtree
must have a low endpoint that
starts to the right of the low
endpoint of j because j in the
left subtree.
And everything in the whole
tree is sorted by low endpoints,
so anything in the right
subtree is going to start over
here.
Those are other things.
These are the i primes in R.
We don't know how many there
are, but they all start to the
right of this point.
So they cannot overlap i
either, therefore,
there is nothing.
All the i primes in R is also
nobody.
Just to go back again,
the basic idea is that since
this guy doesn't overlap the guy
who is in the left and everybody
to the right is going to be
further to the right,
if I go left and don't find
anything that's OK because I am
not going to find anything over
here anyway.
They are not going to overlap.
Data-structure augmentation,
great stuff.
It will give you a lot of rich,
rich data structures built on
any ones you know,
hash tables,
heaps, binary search trees and
so forth.